government
thanks okay so I
somehow things are going slowly than I
planned but fortunately during the break
I realized they have an easier proof of
what I was going to do uh which for some
reason I never noticed so I think let's
let's do that it's Gonna Save Us a
little bit of time so let me just remind
you the main level we needed to show is
the following so we have these stopping
time saying that you know it's it's the
first time where the gradient of effort
X stays is you know bigger than some
constant in Norman this constant is a
universal constant that we're going to
uh fix uh like determine its value later
on and dilemma just says the following
things like
not only that in so so recall that the
expectation of of the integral of this
maybe
the expert in expectation the integral
of T gradient f x t
squared DT is equal to the variance of n
this will determine but this Lemma says
a bit more it says not only an
expectation but there is also
non-negligible probability
that it's going to be like at least the
constant so in instant this is stronger
right
and and actually so there's uh a pretty
easy proof I I you know you remember I
formulated Lemma B but since I have uh
we don't have a lot of time let me just
give you an easily direct proof of this
lemon so sorry that I like
I was planning to to do something a bit
more General but let's just prove this
and that's it so
first we'll show it
first assume
that f is balanced or nearly balanced
first assume that like the variance of f
is at least I don't know one over a
hundred
and then I want to show that you know
the probability of this is at least you
know some other constant
in this case what we do is the following
so
recall that the expectation of
the quadratic variation of the
Martingale M at the time one is equal to
the expectation of this integral between
0 and 1 T gradient f
x t
squared DT
now the exact same proof that we saw
allows us to replace one here by any
stopping time top
like it it just doesn't matter at all
it's it's true up to any time
like one had no importance whatsoever
but it's if we actually don't care that
it's a deterministic Time the exact same
proof works for like a stopping time so
let's use it with the stop in time tone
and now let's uh recall that the
variance of f
which we assume to be at least 1 over
100 for now
is equal to the expectation of the
quadratic variation
that's time one which is equal to the
expectation of the quadratic variation
at the time so Plus
the expectation of you know the
quadratic variation of time one minus
that time zone
right
now Let's uh try to bound each of these
terms separately so what is the
quadratic so the expectation of the
quadratic variation in time tone is this
expression but the definition of toe is
telling us that you know as long as uh
did not
arise
the the
this gradient is small right so we know
that
this thing here
is by definition less than
c squared
meaning that also like this entire thing
sorry that the first term
is bounded by you know the integral up
to 12 some integrounded
smaller than c squared so in particular
this whole thing is less than c squared
right
now what about the second one
well
if ta is equal to one then it's just
zero right
and
if toy is less than one so I claim that
it's less or equal than the probability
that 2 is less than one which was
otherwise it's just zero times
now conditioned on on top being less
than one the quadratic variation is at
most it's in fact this thing it's the
expectation of the variance
of M1 minus M2 this is exactly again
eto's isometry given
that tau is less than one
strictly less than
so
in fact this is an equality here for the
second term
but this term well it's a variance of
something that is always bounded between
minus one and one so
this so this thing is just
smaller than one
which means that all of these 10
is is less than this probability
so
this expression is less than c squared
plus the probability that so is less
than one
right
now if I take C small enough and move it
to the other side so take you know
D is one over a hundred
then we get
that the probability that store is less
than one is you know at least
uh
1 over 200.
questions about this
okay
now this was just the case where so so
we already proved this inequality of
Terra grant for the case of you know
nearly balanced functions but what
happens if the variance of f is actually
much smaller
that's not a big problem because we can
I'll just kind of sketch the argument I
I won't write anything down so
if we look at the Martin Yale Mt
so I have here like
zero and one empty m0
starts from this is basically uh the
expectation of f
which is I mean when the variance of f
is smaller than you know expectation of
f is more or less the order of the
variance
an empty is a modern like it's like
between zero and one and whatever the
time one it reaches either zero or one
now
the point is that the probability to
reach one is is exactly the expectation
of f
meaning that the probability that there
exists some t
such that empty
is bigger than one half
is
you know uh at least
the expectation of it
which is in turn at least equal to uh
the variance
times some constant
I mean this is this this inequality is
is true for any
any function which is B like
zero and one valued
so if I draw this some line here at like
one half
then I can just run this Martingale with
probability proportional to the variance
of f it's going to uh reach this line
at some point
and then when when it reached this line
it still happens as a quadratic
variation of constant order to go
so I can just basically
reduce this to what we have just proved
here assuming that the variance is at
least 1 over 100.
so we just run until some other stop in
time let's call it stop rhyme
where f
reaches a point that's bounded away from
you know the edges of this interval
and then once it reached this point we
just repeat this already
okay so we did this basically finishes
uh the proof and we really like used
here the fact that we have a stopping
time and and we it wasn't enough to just
look at expectations we really needed to
show that
the expectation is not supported on a
very small probability event that was
kind of crucial to us
okay
um okay so now in the time I have left I
want to consider another process
so now we you know so far we considered
this jump process uh
XT now I'm going to consider another way
to infinitesimally sample a bit
and for this thing needs just a few
definitions I'm I'm just going to kind
of Define and instead of Brownian motion
because I don't want to talk about
Brownian motions at all and I don't want
to cut to talk rigorously about
etocalculus so I'll just remind you that
DT would just Define it as a small
number
um
one over a million
and T will always be inside
uh is the
times DT
so you know time is continuous but not
really we kind of discretize it
and what I want to Define is so so first
of all like for every process uh
let's call it uh CT
we denote this is just notation d z t
is just Z at t plus DT
minus v t
okay this is
not like a differential it's just
you know a difference but of course all
the formulas we write will still be true
in the limit so if you're comfortable
with stochastic differentials
then you know go ahead and think about
it as a differential
now our Brownian motion we we will just
Define a process BT
bye defining the different dbts
or maybe let me write so that
every DBT is and and
zero DT gaussian
and they are IID for different values of
t
maybe let me call this lattice
Lambda
so for different values of T those guys
are IIT
so you know this is I mean this is how
we should think about a Brownian motion
every infinitesimal difference is just
the gaussian the variance is chosen so
that you know uh so so clearly b t one
minus B T2 for any T1 and T2 is just
going to be you know
and zero uh T2 minus T1
right I just found an independent
gaussians so
a Brownian motion is just uh uniquely
basically defined essentially uniquely
defined by uh this property
um
and and you know this is just a cheap
way that doesn't uh
have to take any limits and yeah
so now
um suppose and that also Define
okay let's
now
so this is the Browning motion okay
now let's BT
vector
uh be uh so we just take a process such
that every coordinate is an independent
Brownian function
be such that b t
I
is a brown animation
okay so the
um
so this is just uh the app that
analog in RN
and
Define
the filtration
ft so for every T of
wise
I can't believe it hold on sorry now my
pencil decided to stop working not sure
why
I do have another one
yeah I'm not sure what's going on today
uh
I don't get it
but okay now it works
I want to Define uh
calligraphic F at time t
to be
the stigma algebra
generated
by
basically the process
be
or
s between 0 and T
so all the randomness is going to come
from these gaussian jumps then I
consider you know conditioning on this
is just condition and one all the
randomness up to time T okay
now
suppose that
stigma
of t
is
a matrix
valued process
touch that
stigma
T is
f t measurable
Define
now we Define a process XD
by the formula d x t
maybe let me put the T here in Brackets
because this is also a vector d x t
is equal
to Sigma t d b t
so
let's let's just uh
stop for a second and like really not
much is happening here I have the
Brownian motion which is just you know a
bunch of independent gaussian jumps one
after the other now
what I do is I consider those matrices
which are just telling me you know BT is
just moving at the same rate in every
coordinate and in every time
those matrices Sigma of T which actually
are all going to be uh
diagonal so maybe it shouldn't okay
but in in general like you can always
take uh
you you can take your gaussian jumps and
multiply them by uh
just just choose the covariance if you
want so so like Sigma tdbt is also a
gaussian jump but the covariance Matrix
is
you know not DT times identity anymore
so the covariance Matrix of this is just
like
stigma t t right
[Music]
and uh and it's easy to see that XT is
always going to be a Mark again
it should be Sigma T transpose Sigma t
the covariance ah sorry sorry Sigma t
squared yeah so of course
yeah our stigmaties are going to be uh
in this talk diagonal but I mean it's
actually useful to consider the general
case
okay
and
the particular choice of Sigma T that we
are going to consider
um
is so that Sigma t
I I
is going to be square root
of 1 plus
x i t
one minus x i t
so in particular this just means I mean
if if we just write the equation this
equation for one coordinate all I'm
writing here is that and sigma t
i j is 0 for I
not equal to J so all I so in like the
particular case I want to consider is
that d x d is equal to square root d x t
i sorry
the X
I of T is square root x i of t
plus one
uh
maybe let me write 1 plus to be
consistent with the above the equation
foreign
it goes to zero when Exile T goes to
plus or minus one sorry this is the plus
and minus
so
this kind of means that you know as when
when I get closer to the points plus or
minus one
I slow down like
you know when when x i of T is is far
away from the edges it goes pretty fast
and when it gets closer it it kind of
slows down and this turns out to be like
a pretty natural
parameterization of like
like a pretty natural way to sample a
bit uh we will see why and what we're
gonna do is we'll try to use this
process
uh to prove
the majority Stables theorem
which is a theorem due to uh
Elgin and Mossel Ryan O'Donnell and
Christopher uh
from I guess zero eight or something
we're going to provide a completely
different proof that
um
turns out to also give better bounds and
this proof is like a
is a joint work with Dan mccullinsel and
press that drug Adventure
so I'll just
give some of the main ideas of how it
works Okay so
I am not going to formulate right now
what majority Stables is and just kind
of going to go from like
let's just try to develop what we can uh
get with this process and actually
formulate it later on
so
as above for any process
XT I'm going to consider a corresponding
Martingale Mt is f of x t
okay
and
now D of m t which is again we remember
it's just a discrete difference
this is equal to
the gradient of f is just the chain rule
the gradient of f of x t Dot
dxt
and
here I need to add something which is
like the a little o
it's it's actually
okay
um
foreign
this is gonna be I mean it's not exactly
equality right because this this thing
is not infinite testimony
but
the the difference is going to be a
little low fixed and we will just ignore
it so I'm not going to keep writing
the term level of TT okay maybe I won't
erase it or just put it in Brackets so
you remember that you know it's actually
there but when we take uh DT to zero
it's it's not gonna be there
so okay and
this is equal to
gradient f of x t and dxt was just Sigma
T times DPT
okay
and
now uh
what is the variance of
of uh m
at any time T what's the variance of n t
this is
um
basically the integral between 0 and T
which is think about it as a sum of V
empty
Square expectation
right this is again
this is basically again ethos isometry
but it's it's not even it was a zombie
tree it's just
you know the variance of the Martingale
is the sum of like I mean yeah it is
sum of squares of the marginal
differences
I'm just writing it in a weird way
because it's like I'm taking the square
of the differential only it's not really
a differential right
which is kind which is by definition you
know the
expectation of
the quadratic variation
right
so again like yeah we could take limits
here and make this won't make sense when
we take limits but both of these sides
will make sense
and I mean that the equality is going to
be true
and moreover
D of the quadratic variation of Mt
is
well what is it it's
um
just equal to
the variance
maybe maybe let me say this it's okay D
the quadratic variation of Mt by
definition is
this is basically DMT
squared which is equal to
which is equal to
gradient f of x t so I'm just I'm just
using this equality
times stigma t
PT
all of this Square
now
if I take
okay and and now
now I'm going to do something which only
works only really works when we take
limit so this is kind of like the only
place where where something special
happens but I think you will
have no problems following the intuition
I'm going to say that this is equal
even though it's not really equal
I'm going to say that this is equal to
just
the gradient of f
times uh
so I guess I guess I'll just say it like
this
stigma t
times the gradient of f
x d
Square DT
okay let's let's see what happens here
okay
this is the square of the gaussian
right
what is uh what's the variance of of
this gaussian the variance of this
gaussian is exactly
this
do you agree
I mean I take a gaussian in RN and
multiplied by a vector the variance of
the gaussian is just like
you know
it's just the the length of the vector
right
now
basically what I did here is I said okay
this equality is I mean
is nonsense right because this thing is
random this thing is deterministic
but since we're always going to be
summoned up a lot of things like this
and since they are uncorrelated I'm just
going to say
at some point we'll always use the low
of large numbers which will allow me to
replace this by its expectation which is
equal to this
so this is something that happens a lot
in stochastic calculus
um and you know why it of course they
don't have time to like make everything
formal but just bear with me on
you know
on on saying that D of the quadratic
variation
which is a random quantity
is just equal to this which is a
deterministic quantity
okay when we sum a lot of them up then
again this this will be this will
actually be true
okay I I hope people are kind of okay
with this this is
yeah I I with the time I have I I have
no choice but just to you know write it
like this
uh
uh okay now what this means for us is
well it means that this then
if if we look at this
which is equal to the variance
this is going to be equal to the
expectation of the integral between 0
and T of stigma T gradient f
XD
in fact this is this is completely
rigorous because
you know we took expectation anyway so
it's okay to also take expectation over
the variances
so
you know in a sense like this Vector
determines how quickly the Martingale
moves
and you know the variance is just the
integral of how quickly the Martingale
moves over you know all the time
which is you know how much the yeah
how much local variance it has
accumulate
okay
now uh
we have uh the following
nice then
which is
theorem called
the level one and quality
which I'm not going to prove well just
state but
the proof is not too hard it's just
there is a little bit of technical work
to do
and it says the following
so it says that
this Vector so
for every
Boolean function
f
and every
X
in minus 1 1 to the end
we have
that
this exact Vector so the the norm of
Sigma T
gradient F at X
is going to be bounded by
I
forever I'll Define what i is
few seconds
I of F at X
Plus
some function
by
of
the gradient at the text
L Infinity
Norm
where
I of it's it really doesn't matter so
much what the function I is but I'll
just tell you it's the uh
gaussian ISO parametric profile
so it's
5 Prime of Pi minus 1 of s
really doesn't matter so
uh where
Phi is the gaussian City app
uh
okay that's a bad
choice for a name let's call this next
time
but this is also a bad choice because I
have no idea how to write sky so let's
call it Psy
is some function
which goes to zero with zero
I don't care what it is
so much
now uh what I do care is the following
if so so what I do care is that
this inequality is saturated by the
majority function so if
f is the majority function
really actually this works for any
weighted majority where none of the
coordinates are too influential
if f is the majority function we also
have the inverse inequality saying that
that this is actually at least
I of f of x
minus
something that goes to zero
uh
when the dimension goes to Infinity
actually okay yeah actually there's no
problem to write exactly the same thing
here because this will go to zero when
we have the majority function
so yeah note that this is the plus this
is the minus so hop up to this
correction
okay
we we basically have sorry
um maybe let me
right it like this like this is equal to
this
uh up to
all of this
so
and and yeah I'm
I I don't have time to discuss this
inequality but
it basically
um
I mean
I I guess it's kind of intuitive if you
want the derivative to be the biggest
possible
you want to take all the mass to One
Direction
so when f is the indicator of the half
space
this maximizes like
the derivative right
Okay so
this is this is kind of a simple
inequality like much much simpler than
majority Stables
that is saturated by that gives you an
some externality over the majority
function and what we're gonna do we're
going to use
kind of bootstrap this inequality to get
majority stables and what majority
Stables says
foreign
basically that uh yeah that
well since I don't have time I'll just
write it like that it's it it basically
says that if maybe let me just write it
for f balanced
actually okay I don't need to write for
f balanced it's for everyone so the
variance
of f
of
um
x t
is maximized
by
majority
up to
the maximal influence of it
and it's an easy exercise to show that
this thing
is actually equal
to what is usually denoted by stab
um
by the noise stability that's of some
function of tof
sorry I I don't have a uh like yeah
since I don't have a lot of time I I you
know I don't want to exactly Define this
and you know discussed it like but
in in a sense what what noise stability
means is you know I I didn't completely
sample
the
the point
X I only samples like a part of each bit
so you know I don't have a process that
is like here on the corners but I have a
process that is somewhere like
here inside
and
noise stability is kind of like how much
variance they have when I only partially
sampled each bit
okay
so
so now uh
we want to say that
you know the variance of F at XD is
bounded by something but
we have this bound and we can just uh
you know plug it
with this thing so note that you know
this exactly bounce the integrand
of this
so
basically what we
can do is the following so
like
Define
NT
so okay maybe let's say that
we're given
a Boolean function and
f is associated
with
a Martingale
empty that we just defined this is the
marginal that samples from that
suppose
G is the majority
function
and let
NTB
the Martingale corresponding to G
foreign
what we have is the following unit we
have the D the quadratic variation of
them
is equal is
equal to Sigma t
f x d
squared DT
which is bounded by I
now I'm using this and quality
no like when when I plug in x equals to
x t this is just empty so it's bounded
by I
of m t
plus this correction term
let's call this correction term Alpha t
Alpha T is just going to be like
the
yeah the infinity Norm
of the gradients
and on the other hand I have that D of
the process corresponding to the
majority function
is
equal to the same thing with g
but we know that g staturates the level
one inequality so it's actually equal to
I of m t
minus beta T so here we have two
correction terms which are
supposedly uh
that are going to be small
and
then we basically have two lemons
so
Lemma one
is going to be
if the maximal influence of f
is little of one
then
this process Alpha T is going to be
small
the maximum uh
T between or maybe
yeah
we can ignore this thing I don't have
the time to discuss why but
I mean may I I think
an easy intuition is the fact that
what is the maximal influence it's the
maximal expectation of the size of any
of the coordinates of the gradient at
time
basically at the final time
so
this is basically saying that you know
each one of these these coordinates is
expected to be small
in the end
so this Lemma is just saying you know
they're also going to be small along the
process
and llama 2 which is uh kind of the
kind of a clean
fact from stochastic calculus
is telling us the following suppose
that
empty
and anti
r
Martin yells
touch that
DMT
is less or equal than stump function
iomt so I'm writing the I because we're
going to use it for the same eyes above
but now I can be any function which is
continuous and positive
and d and T is equal or bigger equal to
I of m t
and this happens like
sorry I forgot quadratic variations
so
for all t
almost surely
so basically uh suppose that I have two
marginals such that
the first Martingale is always moving
slower than the second marginal but I'm
not actually comparing their values at
some time T I just say you know that the
rate of movement of the first Martingale
given its position
is
like slower than the rate of independent
of the second Martingale
then
the variance of
kind of what you expect the variance of
them
T is bigger or equal than the variance
of empty
for all t
okay so like
kind of makes sense right if you have
two more details that one is moving
faster than the other then the variance
of like the one that moves faster would
be bigger
even though you know I'm not again I'm
not saying that the quadratic variation
the like d of the quadratic variations I
can't really compare between them
some
particular time t
and you know like this is
up to the correction this is exactly
what we have here
right so I mean
this just implies that
that the noise stability
of f
thanks
with respect to some
so there is some dependence between the
row that you have to take on the team
but it's pretty easy to derive it it's
just like it's most
the
noise stability of majority
uh last
some correction term that depends on
so the correction
goes to zero
when
the maximal influence
is smart
okay so I I know this was you know
probably too fast like the last part
might have been too fast for some view
but
I hope it gives like a flavor of
uh uh you know like this uh technique
um
let me think if there's uh yeah so so I
do have three more minutes so I want to
I want to try to say something about the
proof of this dilemma because I think
it's very nice this is really like a
Lemma that takes advantage of like
nice Tools in stochastic calculus
and
maybe maybe let's just let me just tell
you the tool that it uses the main tool
it uses is called the dam base
tubing swords there
which tells us the following thing it
tells us that if empty
is a
continuous Martingale
foreign
there exists a Brownian motion
meaning we can Define the Brownian
motion on the same probability space as
empty such that
M at any time T is equal to this
Brownian motion at
the quadratic variation of m x time t
so
what
what this thing says is basically any
continuous marginal can be viewed as
photos
you take some Brownian motion W or or
maybe let me call this w s
because this s kind of lives on a
different uh axis of time as d
and you can change this so so this this
this can be thought of as a change of
time you take W but not at time T but at
the time of the quadratic variation of T
so I mean this this gives further
intuition why the quadratic variation is
kind of the speed of the molecule you
know when it's
when it increases quickly it means that
you know the
the time parameter of the corresponding
Brownian motion needs to increase
quickly
right so kind of the faster this
increases the faster like this process
moves
and
in order to uh
so so once you have this it's actually a
pretty easy exercise to show this Lemma
you can basically just couple these two
processes empty and empty to live on the
same probability space so you can always
always think when you whenever you have
two marginals you can couple them so
that they are both
a time reparameterization of the same
Brownian motion so we can just write
empty
is equal to W at the quadratic variation
of MTN NT equal to W at the quadratic
variation of empty
for the same W so kind of like we first
generate the Brownian motion of
finishing like one minute we first just
generate a Brownian motion
and then to derive what those two
marginals are we just there they they
will each be
a different rep parametrization of the
Browning motion
the the shape will be the same but time
will progress at the different speed so
you know maybe empty will look like uh
this
so
it goes very slowly until it gets to
this point and then maybe it goes fast
until it gets to this point
and then it goes uh like fast again and
then maybe like this part it goes slowly
so I don't know maybe something like
this
and you know Mt will be
some other time requirementization of
the same thing but we know that it's
always moving faster so you just take
this thing and you
you just kind of squash it so anti might
look like this
and when we when we draw it like this
it's kind of clear that like the
variance of Mt will always be bigger
okay I so hopefully that guy at least
got a little flavor of you know this
technique in the last hour um
yeah
sorry that this is all I could say
thank you
[Music]
yeah so you covered three processes like
the localization one and the two
continuous time Martingale processes and
they all boil down to controlling
um for certain stopping times what you
can bound I guess I was wondering for is
there a sense of how you would select
which process to go for for what kind of
problem
um
yeah that's a good question so I mean
I I definitely don't have a short answer
like uh
so for example here it was kind of two
things were crucial
that's the
level one inequality would work and
would be kind of exact and also it's
crucial that the processes are
continuous because if they're not
continuous they definitely cannot have
anything of the sort of like this Lemma
uh
yeah like on the other end if I look at
the telegram thing
it was uh yeah like uh
like what it wasn't actually crucial
that the process is continuous but what
was crucial is that time will will go
from zero to one and not like zero to
Infinity like you know this this this
jump process is kind of okay I don't
have it anymore but like you know the
jump process I know that
X the time one is already in the
discrete hypercube which was kind of
crucial because
like
otherwise I don't know that the gradient
is large at some point so I don't know
there is like
five different processes that also in
canonical and each one has like its own
advantages
um
yeah I probably I don't I don't have a
really good answer
so maybe one comment like so you have
the sigma T right the slowing down of
the process that was to extend it to
Infinity right like because you could
talk about the so you know the objective
was not to extend it to Infinity like
the fact you need to extend it to
Infinity is like a side effect
of the fact that you slowed it down
right
um
yeah
so any other funny questions
I I I missed the question
so but there's one more question uh so
like in this proof like so where do you
like see uh so some some proofs of uh
majority Stables somehow uh control
the theory like hyperconductivity or
like uh like ISO very very technical
quality kind of stuff right so we're in
this like
okay so where does that uh bonding
happen here like like
when you're arguing ah yeah yeah I mean
you need hyperconductivity for Lemma one
naturally which you know I didn't talk
about it at all
I can I really completely swept it under
the carpet right it just yeah
um
yeah
also you use this level one inequality
which uh so is that like non-trivial to
prove or it's no no it's actually very I
mean it's it's just a few lines but
I mean they're oh yeah it's okay may
just
what is this level one inequalities
thing okay like this then uh so Sigma t
f of x d
is nothing but you can just do basically
into sorry uh
Sigma T gradient F of maybe let's forget
about the sigma t
let's suppose Sigma materials identity
gradient f of x t by uh like it's very
easy to say that it's also equal to
integral of x times f of x
sorry maybe okay sorry
from from the top
let's suppose that X is equal to zero
and then Sigma T is is the identity also
and let's just say for x equal to zero
so the gradient of F at zero is just
equal to X
f x
um integral over the display type per
Cube
okay this is like a very easy exercise
and uh so so what is you know what is
this integral like if I let's now divide
by the like integral of f
now the right hand side is just a center
of mass right it's it's the center of
mass of the the you know the stat
defined by F equal to one
right so what the level one inequality
tells you is
if you want to make so given suppose
that I fixed you know the the Integra so
if x is equal to zero then this is just
the integral of it so level one
inequality in this case just tells me
that like Center of mass of f
and
is
smaller than
I of integral of f
over integral of that
right
so
it just tells me that you know this the
center of mass and this is maximized by
majority so it just tells me given the
integral given the mass to make the
center of masses as far as possible from
the origin I should I should take the
majority function
but you know this is a pretty easy like
I I mean you know yeah where can I write
so
you know if like this is the origin
and F is the indicator of like this that
I don't know like
maybe this set and the set is not
exactly majority it's not exactly like a
hyperplane it's always better to like
take some hyperplane which is in the
exact same direction as the center of
mass and just push all the mass so maybe
let me draw it just I drew it too too
too close to a hyperplane if you know f
is the indicator of this fact
then
if I take this hyperplane
and I take like this Mass
push it here and here
it only becomes like it only goes
farther right right
that's it that's all there is to the
level one inequality it's a very simple
geometrical yeah thanks
there's one more question
so so this form of covariance Matrix
that you pick
um is it like I'm guessing it's crucial
for obtaining level one I was just
wondering like is it the unique
covariance that
uh yeah great question it's not crucial
for obtaining number one actually level
one you can you actually have a lot of
freedom
for Lemma one to be true you can like
almost any kind of so so you know the
covariance was like a continuous
function of XD and almost any continuous
function that you come up with that goes
to zero at minus one and one you will
still have Gamma One
the
um actually The crucial thing
for which you need this particular
choice is this one is the level one in
quality so the level one inequality that
I just you know showed you an intuition
for the proof this equality is only true
for x equal to zero
but when X is X is not equal to zero if
you want an exact equality for the
majority function the only choice is is
like the the stigma that you know that
we chose
I see thanks
so you can take more questions offline
and maybe we'll have a break thanks
again
cool
thanks guys